you
my flavor here deep in the jungles of
Studio City what's going on you bad
[ __ ] it's Tuesday September
20th swinging dick and giving our
bubblegum the sun's out the birds are
chirpin the lizards are moving blades
still be slinging dick even if it was
cloudy with a [ __ ] tornado cuz that's
how I roll [ __ ] especially a
Tuesday you gotta bring both your
[ __ ] guns to work there's some kinky
[ __ ] going out there I could block the
day house in accordance you understand
me
it's my last day here in that Lane I'm
headed to New York City tomorrow morning
for a fun-filled weekend at Gotham
comedy club I'm gonna go back that and
get [ __ ] blown up there's bombs
everywhere Guttenberg Jersey City
they're all over the [ __ ] place man
what are you gonna do I'm saying what
the floppy
the beauty of this you know what ma'am I
really do what I had to do I prove my
[ __ ] point
they blew me up you light a candle you
smoke a joint yourself
my uncle Joey [ __ ] you can't be
scared of the next [ __ ] level and
trust me it is the next [ __ ]
level people young say I'm good I feel I
hurt my back last week I heard it again
yesterday there'll be no jiu-jitsu to
Lakers at 6:00 our [ __ ] playin rattle
really [ __ ] up my back so I'm gonna [ __ ]
you stick to the guns today I'm just
gonna relax I got a few meetings I have
to see a couple people I don't know if
I'm gonna do a spot tonight I don't know
there's a black cast I've got a lot of
[ __ ] going on so bear with me it would
just pop up on the [ __ ] spot beside
that or you could do this [ __ ] stick
it [ __ ] finger in the dike and pray
you're following me just like Scarface
but enough with the chitty-chat is to
never smoke another [ __ ] bomb oh we
got [ __ ] perennial Skywalker
today this is [ __ ] tremendous you
understand
this is the [ __ ] that [ __ ] killed
Nixon right here [ __ ] I love this
[ __ ] I was smoking weed in the morning
gets me back I could sit back and relax
and see the day as it [ __ ] proceeds
you follow me you know me how am i
living in the [ __ ] moment I got time
to be [ __ ] dippin and dappin nice very
nice tastes tremendous no burn no coffee
no not that nice in the esophagus with
no [ __ ] drum he understand me
none like smoking reefer with your
family on a Tuesday morning till that
[ __ ] know what time it is you
understand me I hate leaving my family
but you know what we all gotta support
him we're another so that's the way it
[ __ ] is [ __ ] sucked if you don't have
your tickets yet forgot them I just got
a call they come fast they won't ask
about my [ __ ] list and [ __ ] so that
means they're moving [ __ ] I'm
gonna have a great time to me how it was
gonna be out a couple of savages from
North Bergen I can't wait to sail and
that's it and that's that let's move
another [ __ ] don't let you guys go into
the [ __ ] darkness you know
and you could be stumped to the [ __ ]
guilt you don't say you go ahead you see
that [ __ ] thing flying that's what
I'm talking about [ __ ]
gotta get you pipes
her Black Sabbath was phenomenal last
night the Hollywood Bowl I'm sorry I
didn't go but [ __ ] him when duty calls
you I'm saying I couldn't don't actually
go understand hopes [ __ ] premiere
last night but I had too many [ __ ]
thing is on my plate just like today
look at that that's a [ __ ] a
heartbreaker right there you blow that
to somebody's [ __ ] or jump up and
down for a month nicey-nice
nice that's the way you start off the
day I was out here 5:00 in the [ __ ]
morning smoking dope I got so high I
felt back to sleep and now I'm a I had
to take the baby to school how to make a
few [ __ ] calls now I'm here with you
[ __ ] getting the day started in
real color you know I'm saying you
didn't will read for the smoke to put
some color in the [ __ ] day and we did
it so that's it and that's that I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing the rest of
the day but I'm busy I don't know if
I'll be at the Dark Horse tonight I'll
let you [ __ ] know but it's
doubtful because I got to be walking
around at 4:00 so I love you
[ __ ] don't let nobody [ __ ] with
your like Tuesday remember the house
will never [ __ ] and I'm saying every
day you gotta pound it right your gold
sling dick yeah this Cox stuff to tell
this guy to suck your dick never ends
but at least you know that going in
stay black uncle Joey loves you see you
Friday and Saturday Gotham [ __ ]